-It is time for "Tonight Show"
hashtags. Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So since Christmas
is next Saturday --
Gosh, that's happening fast.
I sent out the
#AddAWordRuinAChristmasSong.
I asked you guys to just share
your funniest ruined
Christmas songs.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along
on Twitter.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one is
from @depthsofwinters.
He says, "Jolly Old
St. Nicolas Cage."
There you go. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I would listen to that.
This one is from
@theshawnablake.
She says, "I Saw Mommy
French-Kissing Santa Claus."
Oh, that's -- that changes
the song a little bit.
This one is from @JulieH44.
She says, "There's No Place Like
Home Depot for the Holidays."
Ah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Does anyone work here?!
Anyone work here?
Okay, I'll check myself out.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from
@2toneblueblood.
He says, "Rockin' Speedos Around
the Christmas Tree."
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @lukedavy4444.
He says, "Hark!
The Herald Hells Angels Sing."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @alanneal.
He says, "Lap Dance of
the Sugar Plum Fairy."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
-They're really updating that.
It's still called
"The Nutcracker" weirdly.
[ Laughter ]
-Nice.
-Thank you.
This one is from @c2cesp.
He says, "I'll Be Home for
Christmas Arguments."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, that's nice.
That's nice.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @smitdizzle.
-Smitdizzle?
-Smitdizzle.
-Oh.
-He says, "O Little Town of
Bethlehem, Ohio."
[ Laughter ]
This last one here is
from @specialkpk.
He says, "Santa Baby Yoda."
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags,
everybody.
Please check it out.